rustock russell ist und zugeschaltet
militärexperte insbesondere auch für
russland mit dem forschungsschwerpunkt
militärstrategie am european council on
foreign relations und ehemaliger
österreichischer offizier genannte
adresse
also die sache auf der krim das darum
ein russischer soldat versehentlich
neben dem munitionsdepot geraucht hat
und deshalb das ganze dinge die luft
geflogen hat die wird ja eigentlich von
allen experten auch von ihnen für wenig
plausibel gehalten was ist denn ihr
wahrscheinlichste szenario was genau da
geschehen ist das problem ist man kann
hier nur mit wahrscheinlichkeiten
arbeiten dass man kann varianten
ausschließen die ihr unwahrscheinlich
sind dazu gehört natürlich der raucher
unfall und man kann vermuten was
wahrscheinlicher ist also auch
unwahrscheinlich würde ich den
sabotageakt ansehen einfach weil es
schwierig ist am hellichten tage eine
basis unbemerkt ein zu kommen wir noch
keine anzeichen dass die russen nach
irgendwelchen sabotage teams dann im
anschluss gesucht haben also bleibt im
grunde der drohnenangriff oder der
raketenangriff über bei beiden muss man
sagen die bilder sind von alle bilder
die wir von dem ereignis haben sind von
sehr weit weg aufgenommen das heißt es
ist wirklich schwer zu sagen man kann
kaum rückschlüsse ziehen ich halte den
raketenangriff für den
wahrscheinlichsten einfach aufgrund der
art der einschläge der tiefe krater
wäre dann ja ein relativ weit reichende
rakete denn die nächsten ukrainischen
stellungen sind ja dann im süden so um
die 200 kilometer entfernt ja also es
kann sich dabei nicht um die
gewöhnlichen artillerie raketen handeln
mit denen wir es bis jetzt in diesem
krieg zu tun haben wie es kann auch es
sich um nichts handeln was etwa von
seiten der usa oder andere nato-staaten
an die ukraine geliefert worden ist es
gibt ein paar systeme die in der ukraine
in entwicklung waren und es könnten
zumindest prototyp raketen natürlich
gewesen sein die das verursacht haben
das ist etwa wenn wir unsere neptun
erinnern die moskwa versenkt hat diese
rakete da hat er auch niemand gewusst
wie viele und gibt es die jetzt
überhaupt einsatzfähig oder nicht und
dann kam dieser einsatz so ähnlich
könnte das auch mit der chrome gewesen
sein auf jeden fall eine unangenehme
überraschung für die russische seite hat
das weitreichende bedeutung für das
kriegsgeschehen
das werden wir auch sehen ob es jetzt
weitere schläge in die tiefe geht auf
jeden fall macht es die russen nervös
das problem ist diese raketen wenn es
sie wie gesagt in größerer anzahl gibt
eine weit höhere reichweite haben als
die bisherigen durch die ukraine
eingesetzt das heißt eine ganze reihe
von luftwaffenstützpunkten von nach
schubladen von eisenbahn knotenpunkten
kämen dann in die reichweite dieser
raketen nun muss sich russischer seite
gedanken machen diese zu schützen durch
flieger abwehrsysteme beziehungsweise
die logistik weiter zu dezentralisieren
große lager aufzulösen auf viele kleine
zu verteilen um sich weniger verwundbar
machen dann ist man zwar weniger
verwundbar aber dann geht natürlich der
nachschub langsame und das ist dann auch
ein problem man fragt sich ja auch wenn
sowohl die russische flugabwehr gewesen
ist gibt es die nicht oder sind das doch
nur attrappen also die russen benutzen
ja auch attrappen so aufblasbare plastik
luft ab flugabwehrsysteme gegen gegner
täuschen sollen aber die werden ja auch
ein paar echte haben die haben durchaus
ein paar echte das natürlich auch die
überraschende sache denn es sind im
umfeld dieser luftwaffenbasis da gibt es
zwei s400 bataillone die es für 100 ist
ein system dass dieses dass solche
raketen eigentlich abschließen könnte
auch sehen könnte von ihren gerade
anlagen aber ich glaube das
vorhandensein von aufblasbaren attrappen
ist schon ein bisschen ein hinweis das
schiefgegangen ist das heißt nämlich
dass die russen auch angst hatten dass
die ukraine auf der krim rader anlagen
und fliege systeme angreifen deshalb
stellen sie attrappen auf ein weiteres
mittel sich gegen angriffe zu schützen
weil der raketen die etwa die usa
geliefert haben die speziell auf liga
wer raketen abzielen diät dass radler
anteilen also die die elektromagnetische
emissionen deshalb schaltet man
radaranlagen dann ausgeschaltet sie nur
auf standby und hat wenig gerade anlagen
nur im betrieb um möglichst wenig ziele
dem gegner zu bieten das hat aber das
problem wenn jetzt nur ein radio aktiv
ist anstatt vier oder fünf dann hängt es
von diesem einen radler bediener ab ob
er jetzt den raketenangriff entdeckt
oder nicht meinte er am ende der schicht
ist nicht aufmerksamkeit ist diese diese
raketenangriff für die passieren in
bruchteilen von von minuten in der hat
im grunde wenige sekunden auf das ding
zu reagieren und wenn er das verschlaft
und wenn es nur ein raser ist dann ist
das der schaden sofort angerichtet und
jetzt noch mal kurz zum schluss quasi
aus der vogelperspektive drauf gucken
alle die die ukrainische armee versucht
dann die initiative zu kommen also quasi
den russen auch etwas aufzuzwingen was
wo wann geschieht aber
ist das ist die armee inzwischen so gut
ausgerüstet auch vom westen dass sie da
wirklich in die offensive kommen kann
in größeren teilen würde ich sagen fehlt
es ihr noch an schwerem gerät wird noch
ein gepanzerter mobilität gerade im
süden das gelände ist flach da komme ich
ohne schützenpanzer im grunde nicht
weiter die ukrainische armee wird
natürlich auch von tag zu tag stärker
die reserve einheiten die die mobil
gemachten einheiten die werden weiter
trainiert etwa jetzt in großbritannien
die halten mehr gerät von tag zu tag das
heißt man wird stärker auf der
russischen seite nutzt sich der apparat
ab aber wir sind jetzt in einer
situation wo man sich in etwa die waage
hält die russen kommen nicht mehr
wirklich gut voran aber die den
ukrainern fehlt auch noch die feuerkraft
um wirklich große offensiven zu leisten
um kers und wenn sie es schaffen die
brücken zu unterbrechen dann können sie
vielleicht
abgeschnittene russische verbände
schlagen aber größere offensiven würde
ich eher sagen kommen eher ein bisschen
später vielleicht im herbst die
einschätzung von militärexperten gustav
kassel ich danke für das gespräch vielen
herzlichen dank